hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent game to share with you from
round two of the 2023 Tata steel Masters
on the white end of Niche Geary and he's
playing against digukash
opening Wise It's a Queen's Gambit
declined
Bishop B4 signals the regosan defense
in early minor peace and bounce black
with the unopposed dark Square Bishop
and now in this move 8 D takes C4
not so used to seeing the tension
released in general prior to the king
Bishop moving
black is Expediting White's development
now gets to recapture in one move on C4
black has good reason to play in this
way black is well aware of the timing
element and how he is helping the bishop
to develop by capturing so soon
what is the good reason for taking in
this way well first of all I'd like to
say that black wants to work with his
dark Square Bishop
black wants to in other words challenge
white pawns that are on dark squares the
fewer pawns on dark the more
possibilities for Black's dark Square
Bishop
so in other words this guy on D4 is in
the crosshairs black wants to challenge
that point
but to challenge that point while this
tension is present is not a good idea
and here's why
white could continue with C takes d
and saddle black with an isolated Pawn
is this point
a liability or an asset for black I
believe it is seen more so as a
liability black is also down upon in
this position
and it's not so easy to regain it you
take on C4 there's a way the D5 Pawn can
simply fall
okay
in this game black gives up the D5 point
doesn't have to worry about losing it
now
end continues with C5 only on this move
nine
looks to extend the scope
of the bishop with C5 you might say
from here it's castles on pinning the
Knight
C takes D4 and how do we recapture
with the queen Pawn or Knight none of
the above
94.
so this is an instructive moment in the
game
why is this
in between move being flicked in
well I believe it is to duck a minor
piece Exchange
if white in this position captures on D4
with the pawn
this is a fine way for black to continue
by taking the Knight and now white is in
somewhat
awkward position I believe
not losing or anything it's it's an even
position what do I mean by awkward in
this case well white has to
decide do I want to play this position
with an isolated pun
taking with the rook in other words
or do I want to take on the hanging
Pawns
I believe in both environments
white would prefer to have
more pieces on board
when you're in possession of the
isolated Pawn or hanging Pond structure
you should you should be looking to play
dynamically and the more pieces the more
minor pieces for example on board the
more
possibilities for dynamic for your
Dynamic play to be successful
there are only two sets of minor pieces
though
in this situation
in playing Knight to E4 white wants to
play with three minor pieces on board
okay in the game Queen E7 is the reply
if you're concerned at all about these
counter-attacking moves like I am I'd
like to touch on these real quick uh
Maui's testing out lines where I may be
down upon I want to know where my
compensation may be
so a quick answer to Queen F5 you could
you could go with Knight G3 and look to
regain the pawn on your next move Bishop
D3 is also worth uh investigating
further but that's a quick reply in
response to Queen F5 what about Queen G6
what are we doing Bishop D3
and considered best now for black is to
play F5 very weakening
here's how you could be continuing
against a player who is just grabbing
Pawns
and here's the key move Queen B3 a very
strong post
currently white is down two pawns now
but winning
pressure on the bishop pinch Pawn
overloaded Rook
Knight C6 runs into Rook takes Knight
Queen takes Bishop and if the bishop
falls back here comes Knight takes F5
crushing Rook takes Knight Rook takes
Bishop
okay one final note this is a funny one
suppose after Queen G6 Bishop D3 black
says I'm not scared about any night move
with the discovery against my queen so
I'm just going to take a pawn well Queen
is now lost after Knight to H4
where does she go
no say Square
H7 is not safe either
you could go there
everything else is defended directly so
Queen H7 Knight F6 she's one next
okay
counter-attacking moves against the
Knight
no good Queen E7 in this game that is
considered best in now one more in
between move before finally
capturing on D4 and that is A3 very
useful
hard to even assign a single negative to
A3
this bishop is less flexible on A5 on an
open board from A5 it only has seven
options versus nine
B4 has nine options also it's
unprotected on A5
okay from here
we have e takes D4 on this move 13 so
white takes on the isolated Pawn when
he could be sure that's still three
minor pieces three sets of minor pieces
are present
okay from here Rook d8 very sensible
putting pressure on the isolated Pond
looking to control this potential break
and from here Rook to C2 so this was one
of my
one of my main takeaways I would say is
this little maneuver by Geary
lifting The Rook to the second rank what
is the idea it is to next pivot on E2
and that's what we have
Bishop D7
Rook to E2 so this is opposite the queen
do know that there is also another pivot
for The Rook
for example if instead of Bishop D7 if
Knight C6
this is considered best but just to
highlight here's a way you could get to
the D2 Square you cut off the Bishop
from seeing that square with B4
and this move is not only defending the
D4 Pawn but unpinning it so this is a
nice
nice little maneuver Rook C2 to D2
and we're gearing up
possibly for a central break soon enough
could blast open
okay in this game the brook is not
making use of D2
it's Rook to E2
Bishop C6 Queen C2 and now it is already
starting to become a very critical for
black these next couple moves
uh in just a couple moves it's
completely winning for white so I'd like
to touch on what is considered best
right around here for black
in the game Bishop B6 is played putting
pressure on D4 but as it turns out that
pressure is
um that pressure can be ignored by white
there's a big storm brewing on the king
side
there is not a key Defender around for
black there is not a king night around
on F6 or f8 defending the king side
so
considered best in this position is
either to take the Knight on e4 straight
away or Rook to C8
this is considered second rate I want to
highlight both of these continuations
Bishop takes Knight
Rook takes and now Knight to D7 with the
idea to meet D5 with important move now
E5 ensuring that this Bishop's eyes
don't easily open up
to an instruction a structure you have
to weigh very carefully of course white
has this isolated Pawn
um
how are you going to blockade it maybe
putting the bishop on D6 okay one other
continuation
is to play instead of the move played in
the game Bishop B6 is to play Rook C8
Queen gets out of the pin along the C
file and only now the capture and the
the idea behind that fancy Rook move
is that it's stopping this Pawn break D5
now at least for one move
D5 in this position with the queen on D3
rather than C2 that would run into a
fork
so just a couple moves to keep in mind
right here these are improving moves for
black in this position instead of Bishop
to B6 the move played in the game
this or that would have been better
and from here we have
Rook F to E8 so there is something
happening
soon on the king side this last move by
the way is allowing The Rook to now get
to E1 so it's
quite convenient for white to invite
that final piece into the mix
and
black now goes with King to h8 this is
now a winning position
for white
considered best here is Bishop to D5
it's not a fun move to play to be sure
because White's now going to be able to
push would be able to push through with
D5 in the following way
after the capture on D5 you can't take
like this Knight F6 is going to win the
queen maybe deliver checkmate
so this is considered the best
continuation it's not at all fun to play
as black
um but it is apparently savable not fun
to have to take on this isolated Pawn
so this was considered best
in the game it is King to h8 why is this
move being played well there's soon
going to be an accident happening on E6
and wants to get off of this diagonal
it's not hitting with check in some
variations
but here we go now
the move that's crying out to be played
is a move that's going to unleash these
two Rooks so the way you do that is by
moving the Knight
and that is Knight G Knight E to G5
very sharp looking move
threatening maintenance one
how do you defend it the Knight is
captured and now the Rooks come smashing
through E6 is hit
a real lot Rook takes E6
Pawn takes E6 Rook takes E6 and what
does black do
he ends up capturing The Rook
if something else is played this is
going to be me
the queen is being being kicked from
defending G5 so there's no good solution
to these threats
all these pieces are playing for white
and we have spectators on Black's end
so what is trite is Queen takes Rook
Bishop takes Queen Bishop takes Knight
and from here we don't have the
recapture this is one of the ways
forward but the move played very strong
Queen F5 threatening
a mate and two
beginning with Queen H3
this is a really big piece on E6
defending G8 sets up the side
file mates you might say
so what's tried here is Bishop to E4
distracting Queen
away from the mate and two threat Queen
H3 now would allow Bishop to H7
so
we have Queen takes Bishop here is is
there some other try instead of Bishop
to E4
I had a look at this one if rip takes D4
instead of this
we can make use of the newly weakened f8
Square
Queen f8
Bishop F5
and one continuation let's say after G6
G6 there's Queen F7
Queen F6
Bishop E6 this is actually going
straight to Checkmate so let's just play
this one out this this
check and then check Main
that's one way the game could end one
variation after Rook takes
Rook takes D4 in this position
I should have also mentioned after Rook
takes D4 this is stopping Queen H3
because the Rook could block black would
actually be winning in this position
right here
but okay Rook takes D4 is met well with
Queen f8 leading to mate in this game
it's Bishop to E4
Queen takes Bishop
and now Rook takes D4
some other try besides this
such as Rook to E8 can be met well with
H4 and this is essentially inviting
another
um
element into the attack another Pawn
into the attack
so what do you do here if you're taking
the pawn it's going to be mate if you're
playing G4 you just lose the pawn
Queen's still defending looking for main
on H5
and if black tries to develop now we
have these ideas this guy is a big
attacker in this position black has to
give up The Rook for Bishop at this at
this point
and this is still too much imbalance
Queen and three pawns versus the two
miners in a rook
but too clumsy miners in The Rook very
difficult to find
uh coordination with these pieces
okay in this game what is tried is Rook
takes D4
now very nice move
of course well aware of the threats
black has now
Queen F3 defending mate
and threatening me on H5
game continues with G4
Queen F3 King H7 we have the check
King H6 in one final move
Bishop to C2
and black resigns
there's no good solution here for team
black
uh we have a mate threat coming up
by way of h8 G7
have a look at two continuations let's
say The Rook plays here
we could have check on h8
check on G7 King here Queen there
King here Queen there for me
and if the King goes here it's just a
mate like this
one final
test line is this one right here let's
say after Bishop to C2
you know that's stopping me as well
let's save The Rook goes here defending
G7
there's now Queen to F4
King here there's Queen F5
G5 check checkmate
the King goes here there's check
checkmate and some other line if the
king of the king goes here it's made
straight away
oh one final one is in response to this
check right here if G5 is played right
now instead of King to H5 the queen can
make use of F6
G6 and then finally H6 for mate so how
do you slice it it's not going to end
well for team black in this position
there's also a pin on board if the
knight's trying to move taking the Rook
with still threats of coming into that
h8 square
bad news
for team black however you slice it so a
very nice game
and by Geary very nice build up there in
the center with the Rooks forming a
battery on the e-file and then they are
Unleashed
with that star move Knight to E5 the
move that was really crying out to be
played in that position
let's have a look at the tail of the
tape on this one that we could see
and just how accurate Geary's play was
coming in with a 98 accuracy
the big moments right around this move
16 Bishop B6
area and then at this point Rook fe1
King to h8 as as mentioned Bishop D5 was
best but uh wasn't spotted there and it
was downhill
for team black from that point on
uh no inaccuracies mistakes or blunders
for Geary couple blunders for gukesh
coming in with an 87 accuracy
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye